working in retail is like this this
isn't this anyone who works in retail
but it's hard man
as someone who has worked in retail
before you know a lot of people
in college or in high school that get
their first job normally works in retail
and it's normally just to
fuel whatever hobby they have wake up
for yourself man that's like this thing
that i wish i did like i wish i like
just didn't roll over because i i was
very obedient as a kid and i didn't
really like
yeah i was always just taught like
whatever the elders or you know the
person in charge says
yeah exactly they know best right i
don't know what the [ __ ] i was doing at
mcdonald's like what the [ __ ] was i
doing like
i had no idea what i was doing half the
time i just did [ __ ] and i
it would do oh my god i usually spend
like when they were like go get some
fries out of the freezer i used to spend
like 10 minutes just sitting in there
because i was like [ __ ] dude
what am i doing man and it's so hot in
the kitchen
that when you get to the you're like
who's gonna get the fries
you just had a [ __ ] existential
crisis just getting fried
the mcdonald's freezer has become like a
panic room
i would literally just go there for like
five five ten minutes as long as i can
get away with and just sit there and be
like
[ __ ] imagine if you open up the freezer
there's like three other employees
just like everyone's hiding in the
freezer i was so jealous there was this
one dude in this whole job was just
moving the crates into the like freezer
and that was his whole job and i'm like
i want that guy's job
[ __ ] being in front of the deep fryer
man that made my acne so bad
yeah [ __ ] like i remember when i worked
at co-op there would be all these
always these odd jobs that i wish i want
i wish i could get like that would be
one one guy's job was just to [ __ ] go
outside and collect all the trolleys
that people have taken to their cars
that's so nice because you could just
like listen you don't have to interact
with anybody right like that's the best
job because
i was i was always on the till right
yeah and my least favorite part of the
job was when
anyone would like try to make small talk
i'm just like look i'm just here to
[ __ ] stand your food
and take your money why are you trying
to talk to me i don't give a [ __ ] about
how your day is
nope i know i i got that smile talk as
well because like when they talk to you
you gotta smile and you gotta you gotta
be having a good day no matter what's
going on and i'd just be like
i don't know i i would um i didn't have
like any bad experiences
with the customers but uh i mean yeah i
had some like [ __ ] awful managers as
well those cashiers right where they
would like take [ __ ] joy out of iding
you what's up with that you know what i
mean
like if you get that finally my power
it's like literally like i'm being
pulled over by the cops yeah yeah
you for like a beer it's like audi
please
because at that moment in time they have
all they have yeah
like hmm really nice address that's a
nice air to live in
like i hate that like every time like
because because in australia right
like whenever you go to a bottle or when
you go to a liquor store yeah
they have to id like everybody even if
you like clearly look like
[Applause]
challenge
with my dad once and my dad got id'd and
and i remember like he was like
obviously that i did me because i was
like two or whatever right like
obviously but then
the guy looked at my dad and was like uh
id please
my dad my dad's straight up said you're
[ __ ] kidding me
do you know how many gray hairs i have
on my face
of course i'm not [ __ ] 20 years old i
think it was like all right fair enough
yeah i hate that though like it's it's
it's the the it's the movement of
looking down at your id and then just
looking at you with your eyes like this
yeah it's that movement i'm like what is
this [ __ ] l.a noir like
i i i would hate the process when
whenever i was working co-op and i had
to ask for id because i was 16 at the
time as well
it just for me it just felt wrong asking
someone for id when
i was obviously like younger than them
yeah so anytime i'd have to ask the ask
for id it'd be like the most nervous
stutter
like it would be like it would be like
it was as if like the power dynamic was
like the other way around
so i'd be like okay can i can i
have your id please and honestly like if
they gave him their idea i'm just like
okay they're probably
oh overrated god i don't have the balls
to ask my manager to come check this man
can you check this guy's id please
if they've gone through all the trouble
getting the fake id just give it to him
yeah yeah
why not no it was it was like remember
your 18th birthday though
the first time you go to go to buy like
a [ __ ] bottle of beer
and admittedly i don't remember my 18th
birthday for numerous reasons
i don't remember what i did but i do
remember being like yeah being able to
finally
i remember that first pint or that first
beer that i got
and i was like it was like the biggest
[ __ ] empowering power trip that i've
like
that i had felt in my 18 years of living
until then i was living life on the edge
before that you know